[Musique]
et si pour ces vacances vous replonger
dans les comptes ceux du célèbre charles
perrault cendrillon le petit chaperon
rouge ou une petite nouvelle peau d'âne
à voir dans un château bonjour mélanie
ou jean caby peau d'âne s'est refait une
beauté au château de breteuil puisque
depuis près de 40 ans le château met en
avant les célèbres contes de charles
perrault et vous devez citer
quelques-uns la scène de peau d'âne elle
existe depuis 30 ans mais cette année
elle présente un nouveau visage en 2018
dans le lavoir nous avons modernisé
remis au goût du jour avec des sons et
lumières technologies plus modernes
cette les enfants maintenant on
recherche la technologie il faut que ça
bouge plus interactif
donc le comte tatic comme il y à 30 ou
35 ans n'était plus vraiment au goût du
jour et jean-emmanuel charreaux a donné
déjà plusieurs indices sur cette
nouvelle peau d'âne on a donc hâte de la
découvrir
je vous faire patienter encore un tout
petit peu camille si vous me permettez
pas ce que pour voir la princesse il
faut s'éloigner un petit peu du château
quelques pas qu'on fait dans la forêt
l'axé déjà chéri pour moi j'y suis allé
pour découvrir cette photo d'anne 2018
il faisait super bowl et les oiseaux
étaient chanteurs et donc on doit aller
jusqu'au lavoir pour profiter des 6000
d'histoire bonjour vous êtes impatients
takami alors on parle directement
découvrir cette princesse à la voix si
pour cette nouvelle mise en scène de la
vidéo peau d'âne s'anime de manière
originale on le voit sur les images
grâce à un vidéoprojecteur que le
village de la princesse apparaissent et
grâce un vidéoprojecteur pardon dans sa
robe est comme un écran de télévision et
comme la scène ne dure que quelques
minutes
il a fallu faire un choix dans
l'histoire et c'est christophe le
scénographe qui nous en dit un peu plus
j'ai décidé de ne présenter qu'un
extrait du compte comme on relit le
compte à un lieu de la vie d'autrefois
j'ai évoqué le passage ou peau d'âne se
retrouvent et se réfugie dans une ferme
où elle va nettoyer loges des cochons et
là
les torchons et donc c'est son travail
et sa vie à la ferme qu'on évoque alors
si vous aussi vous vous demandez ce qui
arriva peau d'âne le château est ouvert
tous les jours à partir de 10 heures et
en plus de cette princesse cette autre
histoire sont à découvrir